all right uh thanks very much ayal for
that introduction and thank you for the
committee twin for inviting me
so um indeed the previous uh
talk is a perfect uh introduction to uh
lead to the topic that i'll be talking
about
however i also want to let you reassure
you just in case some of you
did not become experts on multi-leader
maps based on sanjim's excellent talk
most of this stock should still be very
understandable to you
all right and of course uh as has been
said before this is supposed to be a
fun thing so please interrupt and ask as
many questions as
as you'd like all right so
suppose that you have a secret okay
most of us have secrets but
unfortunately for you
you have an adversary and
even more unfortunately for you this
adversary has actually
captured your entire brain okay
and not only has he captured your entire
brain
he's able to read and tamper with
every single neuron within your brain
understand the entire structure of all
the neurons in your brain
and in fact he can do this while you are
thinking about the secret that you want
to protect
right so this sounds pretty horrible
right of course there's some slight
physical discomfort that might be
involved here
but you know putting that aside um
more fundamentally you know there is
this
inner sanctuary of our mind right that
we all
rely on and to have that
violated would be it's a horror story
it's like a horror novel right
this is just pretty terrible
luckily for us this does remain
science fiction i'm not here to talk to
you about
capturing people's brains
but if you think about it the computer
science
analog of this situation happens all the
time
right the computer science analog of
this
is that you have your brain which is
some software
right that is running on some computer
and
that software is completely captured
by an adversary right in fact most use
models for software just
assume this that an adversary will get
access to your software because you're
releasing it or you're selling it
even in cases where that's not part of
the use model
insiders or malwares typically come and
find their way to get
a hold of your software right so
this sort of horror story for humans
happens to poor computer programs all
the time
right and we're here to protect the
computer programs
so what we would like to do is ask the
question
you know can a computer program keep a
secret
even if the adversary captures that
entire program
okay and i want to stress that we're in
a situation here
with no trusted hardware no interaction
among different parties we just have an
ordinary computer program right with
ordinary inputs and outputs
not encrypted inputs and encrypted
outputs nothing like that just ordinary
inputs and outputs
where the program is making use of some
secret right to compute its input output
behavior
but the inputs and outputs themselves
are not special in any way
right and
it's again just running on a single
ordinary computer
that is a computer who that is entirely
public
everyone knows the construction's
computer the initial state of this
computer is also completely public
there's nothing secret about it
right okay so that's what we would like
to study here
before we go to that let's just
step back for a moment and think about
earlier concepts
that the vast majority of you know and
love and
uh you know we're talking about secure
multi-party computation
introduced by yao goldrich mcgalley and
wigderson ben or goldwasser wigerson and
you know many beautiful beautiful works
over the last
many decades now usually when we talk
about
secure multi-party computation you know
we think about multiple parties that are
talking to each other as the name
suggests but i want you to think about
it a little bit differently let's take a
look at the notion of secure multi-party
computation
through the lens of the mind-reading
mind-reading adversary
right so think about our
brain which is performing some
computation
and now in the secure multi-party
setting what we're thinking of is that
we take this brain and just subdivide
it right into little parts of the brain
so the brain
little parts can think within that part
it can also communicate with other parts
um of the brain right and then what
secure multi-party computation asks
is what if an adversary can come
and see what's going on in for example
one of these
parts of the brain right and can
read and tamper with and you know take
over that one part of your brain
right can we still have security and
indeed in the most
aggressive setting in the case of n
minus one corruptions
right we have a situation where an
adversary can corrupt
all but one of these subdivisions right
of the brain
and we would still like to argue uh that
there's security
right and we have been able to do this
for for decades now
um where the mains oh sorry before i say
that
but but again what's critical here
what's critical in the setting of secure
multi-party computation
is that there's always at least one
honest party
right that there is one part of this
brain
that is completely blocked from the
adversary the adversary has no idea
what computation is taking place there
he can't tamper with it he can't do
anything to it
right and this is really the key point
in
secure multi-party computation and this
leads to the main solution idea right
that we've developed over the last many
decades right which is
in some sense to take the computation
kind of spread it out you know in some
way throughout this whole
brain using secret sharing right
and in that way as long as the adversary
misses at least some one part
of the computation then he's missed the
essential of every
part of that computation right so
um so that's what we've been looking at
before
these kinds of models have been
generalized
uh for example uh if you look at this
idea of a leakage-resilient compiler
right that takes this idea um
of your full computation
um where now it's not necessarily
subdivided in any particular way but
that there's some leakage going on
some somebody's squeezing this brain and
getting some information out of it
um subject to various conditions that
i'm not going to go into they're not
relevant to this talk
but again it's critical that the leakage
is always strictly less than one
right that you don't actually get all
the information that was again
the main idea in uh the work on leakage
resilient
cryptography so the co
you know the common thread if you look
at these previous works
is that there's some portion right of
this computation that's completely
hidden from the adversary
and that's really where the fundamental
break is right when we're looking at
obfuscation
there is no part of the computation
that's hidden
and so here you know just spreading out
the competition can't
can't help you right because the
advertiser can follow you down
everywhere in every nook and cranny
of the computation and figure out
everything that's going on right
so so that's the fundamental challenge
that we're going to be dealing with
all right so um great so we would like
to
hide program hide secrets in programs
right
another difference with the secure
computation setting is that
this is not as straightforward a
question as uh
as perhaps it was in the context of
secure computation protocols
because it's not that every program that
can even hide a secret
this is a trivial example suppose that
we have a program
that has some constant uh built into it
some constant s and the program just
takes an input x
checks if it's less than s if so outputs
one otherwise it outputs zero
right and perhaps someone would like to
keep this constant secret right this is
the yao's millionaire
problem right this is actually a very
well motivated program
but it's obviously hopeless right if i
take this program
as long as i maintain its functionality
there's no hope of hiding this constant
s because i can just do binary search
and find the secret in that way right
so excuse me uh
so certainly not every program even
interesting programs
are even amenable to the possibility of
hiding secrets within them
um and for secrecy to be plausible at
all
we definitely need that the program
should be unlearnable
with queries right that the secret
especially that we're trying to hide
should not be learnable just by making
input output queries to the program
right um and this leads to a natural
hope that we could try to
define our notion of uh obfuscation
to only allow what you can learn with
queries
right so just to do this idea of a
virtual black box that
i take my program i obfuscate it and
what i end up with is something that is
just as useful
um as just having input output access to
that program
right very natural
so this worked for a few seconds right
now
but you know so what happened was back
in 2001
this idea was formalized um in in our
work and then we ruled it out
so this was uh unfortunately too good to
be
uh to be true in general okay
um what do i mean by that let me make
that very very precise because this is
an easy
result to misinterpret so we mean
something very precise
what we showed is that there exists
some very contrived okay extremely
contrived
programs that i'm going to call
self-eating programs
for which black box obfuscation would
suffer from
explicit attacks so again the positive
thing here is there are actually
explicit attacks we're going to be able
to
despite the fact that this program is
not one that you can
extract a secret out of just with black
box access
we're still going to explicitly show you
how to get a secret out of it
okay just by giving any uh obfuscation
obligated version of it but of course
the bad thing is that it's very very
contrived and i've never seen a
interesting program that behaves in this
way
except for interesting to us so what's
the idea
right the idea is that we're going to
make a program
that takes some input x it'll have some
secret
constant inside of it that's not really
that important right now
but what the program does is
informally speaking it just checks if
the input
is actually a program that is equivalent
to itself
okay now of course in general this is
undecidable or at least very hard
problem
but we designed this program in such a
way so that the key property
is something that can be checked in this
way right
and if the input happens to be a program
that is actually equivalent to p
then it just outputs a secret otherwise
it outputs zero
right and now the point is
that if i only have black box access to
this program i only am giving it as a
black box
it just looks like a zero function right
anything i could guess
and try to feed to it is extremely
unlikely to be
equivalent to this program p that we've
constructed
and therefore it will just say zero zero
zero zero zero zero
right so for black box access you can't
hope to learn
the secret s but on the other hand any
obfuscation of this program
would allow you to learn the secret
trivially right just take the obfuscated
version
feed it to itself and out pops a secret
right
so um this can be made precise and
formal i won't go into the
to the details of that um but again this
is an explicit attack this one right
here
but it's a pretty contrived contrived
case
i do want to stress that all the
negative results we have
for obfuscation are of this
type they have some sort of pathological
component
either with respect to the program
itself that you're trying to obfuscate
or with respect to some auxiliary input
that you're supposed to give to the
adversary together with the program that
you're trying to obfuscate where that
itself would be some other obfuscated
program so there are
these kinds of um contrivances that
exist
for all all the non-negative results
so if i wasn't at the simons institute
for the threat for
theoretical computer science um i might
talk about
uh why perhaps in practice it's still
reasonable to think about the vb
definition
but we're at the science dude for
theoretical computer science and so it's
a theory talk
so i won't explore this idea further so
basically for us
because we don't get this notion we
cannot get this notion in general
we want to move on and try to look for
other definitions
yeah so the negative results are all
contrived
but the positive results are very small
too right
there what are the positive there's also
not known for natural classes we have
neither
positive nor negative that's a good
point you know i didn't i don't have a
slide on that i i should have i should
have probably
summarized it before the recent work
there were very very small positive
results for
certain little classes of functions like
hotek's
point function obfuscation and the
random oracle model
a little bit more than point functions
so it's true
things like that and then yeah we have
neither positive or negative
results for vbb right right
um i mean now we can get back to this in
in light of the newer results
where um
it's not yeah okay so one other thing i
want to point out
that this is a contrived program but in
fact uh
because of very clever low complexity
crypto
things you can actually make such a
program
in a very low complexity class a
relatively little complexity class
something like tc0 all right
so as a result
you cannot hope to get a general
positive result even for
very wimpy complexity classes for vvvp
obfuscation
other special cases certainly remain an
active area of investigation
yeah you seem to hint that if this
wasn't the theoretical conference
you have something interesting to say
well i i i mean i i i i i
i don't know what interesting but uh no
i mean i i've already made the main
point here right that
there are contrived uh negative examples
it's the same thing that we have for the
random oracle model right in random
oracle model we have contrived
negative negative results on the other
hand
we don't seem to have any attacks right
in the real world with
in situations where the random oracle
model is deployed
and we may argue similarly that uh it
makes sense to think about it that way
but we are at the simons institute right
now and you know we're so so let me let
me let me let me proceed on the theory
side
yes
so if you think about the pharmaceutical
for practical point of view objectives
if you think about things
as either learnable or not in the sense
that they are prf then this is not
contrived at all this is just you know
your schedule or prfi
essentially no because again the the
contrivance is this
right it's the fact that you check and
then you spill your guts
right that's the contrived part what
what why would someone
on purpose put a trapdoor into their
program that
asks for a something essentially
equivalent to itself like it just
that's the part that i'm saying is
contrived but i think that if but i
think that it follows that if you can
office create a prf then you can
actually obfuscate everything and
therefore
actually that's not that's not that's
not obvious and in fact that's a really
interesting question
um questions of composability for vivi
obfuscation
are still largely open so um that's
actually a very interesting area to
to think about that would be an
interesting way to hope to get beyond
that maybe then we could get a negative
result without any contrivance but
but as of right now we haven't gotten
there yet
all right um good so
uh all right so we want to move past vb
obfuscation
and actually in that same paper we
introduced or we we suggested an
alternative
um really kind of just you know writing
by analogy
you know we have all these
indistinguishability based definitions
in cryptography so
you know we thought hey let's just think
of a natural indistinguishability style
definition for obfuscation
and we went through a bunch that didn't
work but this one was a natural one
that that which is the following okay so
let me just tell you what the definition
is
um for any program p uh
the obfuscated version of that program
should be it should
retain the functionality right so for
any given input x
the obfuscated version of p on input x
should equal p of x
okay and the time
incurred by the obfuscated program on
any input
should be some fixed polynomial in the
time incurred by the original program
okay so this is just basic stuff what's
the interesting thing the interesting
thing is the actual security definition
and here we all we want
is if i have two completely equivalent
programs p0 and p1
that is for any input x p0 of x equals
p1 of x
right if we have completely equivalent
programs of the same size
which i'm going to continue to ignore
for most of this talk
then it should be true that no
polynomial time
adversary can distinguish between the
obfuscation of p0
and the obfuscation of p1 and i included
these here just to make the point that
even if the adversary knows
which are the two programs in in the
clear you know p0 and p1 ahead of time
he still shouldn't be able to tell given
the obfuscation whether it came from p0
or whether it came from p1
okay so by same size what's the mean
time
right okay so um mostly for this talk
it's better to think about the program
just being a circuit then the question
um would be yeah the same you know it
should have the same structure
in that in that in that sense um when we
think about turing machines
the sort of uh nice way to think about
it is that the output of a turing
machine
is the time it took to run on that that
input together with its output
and that way you just fold it into this
definition
but yes obviously if the running time
itself
was revealing then we we can't hope to
be faithful to that right and still and
still have an obfuscation
all right um and of course the
obfuscator itself i o here
should be a probabilistic polynomial
time algorithm right
and pal do you have a question yes
it's more of a sort of philosophical
question what does it mean well the best
kind
yeah what does it mean that p0 and p1
are are different so p1 is in fact an
obfuscation of p0 so when i go to
obfuscate p0
my first step would be the obfuscation
of writing it as p1
and then i'd obfuscate them both in the
same way
well okay that's a good point so let me
let me let me first just clarify
even though both p0 and p1 are given to
the distinguisher
the obfuscator only gets one program as
input so the obfuscator only knows
p0 and he has to obfuscate it only
looking at p0 he can't know that there's
a p1
right so that's one point the other
point is that
p0 and p1 in fact i mean as craig will
tell us tomorrow
when he gives us several nice examples
of how to use indistinguishability
obfuscation we'll see examples where p0
and p1
are definitely not obfuscated you know
if you looked at them in the clear
there would be all kinds of secrets
popping out at you but nevertheless
they're equivalent and therefore you can
still
exploit this definition that wasn't the
question okay
sorry i was saying let's say i want to
obfuscate p0
my first step would be to write p1 and
then i'd obfuscate
how do you know what p1 is i don't
i'm saying it was a philosophical but i
still thought
all right okay all right um
it's not 100 clear to me
why would you ever be able to
distinguish because i'm saying
they're exactly the same the programs
what does it mean that they're even
different
okay good so that is actually a really
excellent question
okay so the point is right quality of
questions
sorry what i mean by that is this that
this definition certainly when we
thought of it back then
we thought it was a useless definition
right because of the point that you're
making
right that if these two questions if
these two programs p0 and v1 are
functionally equivalent then what can
you hope to do from this
right and so we'll see the answer to
that tomorrow
especially tomorrow a little bit maybe
i'll also mention today but
but uh but but but it turns out to be
surprisingly useful
um isn't it useful because the actual
skater
is polluting time if the after skater
was absolutely
ah that's a good so in fact that's my
next slide right here my next next next
next the very next thing because it
might also answer your question
so here's just a curious fact okay
usually if p equals np that's terrible
news for us as cryptographers right
well it still still use our terrible
news for us as cryptographers
but but interestingly enough ios for io
for circuits would exist unconditionally
if p equals np why because i could just
take the circuit
if p equals np then the hierarchy
collapses which means i can compute
minimal versions of a circuit right
in fact minimum i can take the
lexigraphically first circuit
that is equivalent to my input c and
just pad it out to the appropriate size
and this would be an
indistinguishability obfuscation which
is kind of i think what you're saying
right
the point is that what we could do is
take the input they take the program p0
and just find the smallest version of it
and that is an obfuscation
according to the i o definition right
and in fact it would work if p equals np
because you could do it efficiently
right um what's that lots of good things
after this
for something lots of good things also
happen
on the assumption that feels different
this is an excellent point yes yes yes
you should always look at the
the glass is half full yes yes yeah also
other little things like building
nuclear power plants and yeah you know
other stuff like that okay all right
um so uh yeah i mean obviously
uh despite the professional consequences
i still would be very happy if p equals
np
um all right so uh so what does this
mean
aside from this interesting observation
it also
means that io cannot imply hardness by
itself right because it exists if p
equals np
so there is no hardness right um but
again as we'll see tomorrow
i o can be used really
quite successfully to leverage hardness
so i o
plus one way functions gives you a lot
of interesting stuff yes
so i understand that io is very useful
but i don't understand in which way
does it hide secrets right
and again um that
we will see mostly uh in to talk
tomorrow by craig
um but i'll give you a ver you want me
what are you sure
where's craig i'm promising a lot you
know
look okay i mean um
you know what let me can i postpone that
and i can give a quick example of you
like
maybe a little bit later yeah no a
philosophical answer to that will
you just like when when encrypting
something you hide everything by the
length so you say two things that are
the equal length you cannot distinguish
whether you encrypted the first or the
second
here you hiding everything except the
functionality for two so two things that
have very cool functionality you cannot
tell
a good a good analogy you know
a good analogy would be witness and
distinguishability right
witness and distinguishability is
incredibly useful
right even though it doesn't look all
that useful maybe if you look at it
at first glance and it's going to be
similar in in the way that we're able to
exploit this
okay so just a small technicality so
these
i mean the definition these would be
these classes of families of
programs that you are comparing that
equivalent right yes yes
this should all be parameterized but
because i mean if i add all the
notation for that it would just become
too cumbersome that but
absolutely we're talking about families
of circuit ensembles you know that's the
right way to talk about this
all right um so the nice thing about
this
definition is that there was no
impossibility results
there were no impossible results known
for this definition
but on the other hand it was open for a
long time and kind of useless seeming
for a long time
um but then again the reason why i'm
here is that
two years ago with sanjim who you heard
from earlier today
craig who you'll hear from tomorrow shai
who you heard from
also yesterday mariana who is also in
the audience
somewhere and brent
we we had the first candidate
construction
for um for this idea of
indistinguishability obfuscation
based on multilingual maps and and i'll
talk more about that of course in the
rest of the talk today
um and as i mentioned turn out to be
surprisingly useful
um again you'll hear more about that
tomorrow but since we're at the simon
institute i'll just mention what the
simon's magazine said so in the simon's
magazine article
you know it was entailed as a watershed
moment because of all these consequences
that that io ends up having
so um all right so what will i talk
about for the rest of
the rest of this tutorial um we want to
talk about
uh constructions and security so that's
the purpose of this talk to talk about
how do we actually do this how do we
actually build
obfuscation and what kinds of security
proofs can we uh can we give i'll take
you to the
price point okay so
are you sad does my time with the answer
you got
um
yes yes we should ask paul to answer the
questions
so when do people always talk about
obfuscation right they want to obfuscate
games right so that you'd be able to put
your game out there
and nobody would be able to steal it and
so on
so so yeah everything exactly
said so this does not offer you anything
that would help
indeed as i said i mean really there
were there was essentially a decade
in which uh no one really thought of of
any real applications for this
uh we did have one application right at
the very beginning which is kind of cool
but
i'll get to that a little bit later um
okay let me try to offer one more little
preview of
of craig's talk right so here's another
way to think about it
okay so the two key technique
right that we all know and love you know
uh
right where you encrypt something and
you encrypt it again right
so think about a decryption program for
that right
there are two ways you could do it you
could use secret key one
or you could use secret key too as long
as you can somehow
ensure that only valid ciphertext would
ever be decrypted
which we will and i think greg will talk
about it yeah okay
um then these two programs
one that uses secret key one and the
other one uses secret key two
are functional equivalent right they
always decrypt every single ciphertext
exactly the same way
and yet by io
you wouldn't be able to tell whether
you're using the secret key one program
or the secret d2 program
but as long as you can decrypt them yeah
i don't care exactly
why do you care okay that's a i mean
but again you know think about the two
key thing like why did we care then it's
because of a hybrid argument right you
were able to
just set it up in an appropriate way
exactly yeah so so there are various
dance
hybrid dances that we can we can engage
in that got us there
please please please craig is going to
answer all your questions craig you know
all right but again today i mean right
now i would like to talk to you about
constructions
and security how do we get this mythical
object
this is recursive you know i'm a little
bit worried about this
all right
okay so um so how are we going to attack
this problem how are we going to
construct these objects
um at a super duper high level uh
the way that the current approaches work
is
an idea that i'll call structured noise
okay the idea is that let's think about
this program that we want to obfuscate
and somehow
take excuse me each component of that
program
and noise it right in a way that
individually looks kind of random
okay but magically
we're going to design the structured
noise in a way
that if the user or the adversary
combines the program components the way
he's supposed to
according to a normal execution of the
program
then at the last possible moment just
before he's about to get his
his his output the noise cancels out and
the output emerges
okay but on the other hand if the object
tries to combine these components in any
other way
or modify them then that noise will
remain there
and it will hide what's going on hide
all useful information about what's
going on
that's at a really high level that is
the idea that we're going to be
exploiting
that's the idea and some of the way that
was exploited by in sanjim's talk
and we're going to continue exploiting
it here okay this is just a super high
level thing
it's okay if you if it doesn't make a
lot of sense
oh i hope it did all right so let's jump
straight into it let's get right into
the
the heart of the matter um let's talk
about how
to actually obfuscate a program we're
going to be talking about obfuscating
matrix branching programs which i'll
define and and
and discuss in just a moment okay and
here we're following a present
presentation of uh in a joint work with
uh boaz sanjam yael
omer somewhere and uh
yeah that's it okay and me okay so
um we're working with multi-linear maps
um you guys just uh had two hours on
this but i'm going to
change the notation slightly so let me
just remind you what the situation is
that we're going to be working with
okay so the formal setting that we like
to work with
is that we have a universe
of one up to k k is kind of the maximum
in the situation okay and for every
non-empty subset of this set
one through k we're going to have a ring
g sub s okay and each of these rings
is just a copy of the integer's modulus
and large
number n okay
and uh as an example suppose
k equals 2. in that case my sets are
the set containing one the second
containing two instead containing one
two right
and each of these rings are just copies
of zn
okay and i'll use brackets to with
as as shown here to talk about an
encoding of two in this particular ring
i'll just talk
predators two and the ring one okay
n is the same for every subset and it's
the same for all of them
they're isomorphic and that's very
important and in fact yeah they're
there are nice comfortable normal ring
of integers module a large number
now what can you do with these what
operations do you have
you can add and addition is restricted
to working within one of these rings so
within gs and gs you can add two things
together and get something else in gs
again just as an example if i have two
and seven both included at level one
i can add them and i get nine on the
other hand addition only works in this
case so what's not allowed
is taking an encoding of two at level
one and seven
at level two and add them together these
things will not fit together they will
not add
okay yes the connection between this
notion where you have the subsets and
the
previous notion where we had the levels
it's just basically what
sanji was talking about was taking the
single number the single polynomial z
or number and the clt case and just
raising it to a power
here we'll have z1 up to zk
different polynomials and you just
multiply them all together
in the zero testing so that's the cheat
sheet
to go with what tangent was saying okay
all right so again we have addition we
can add within the group we cannot add
across groups
across strings now multiplication is
different
multiplication is if i have g sub s and
g
sub t and s and t are disjoint
then i can multiply and go to the union
okay so again as another example
if i have two and three encoded at
levels one and two i could multiply them
and jump
to the level one two right on the other
end if i had two things both at level
one
then it's not allowed because these are
not disjoint sets and therefore
you it just wouldn't work okay
and this is exactly what sanjim was
saying just in a slightly different
terminology um
and then finally of course the real
really important point is we have the
zero test right so at the final level
at g corresponding to the set one
through k
if you have an encoding of an element
there i can go to the zero
test and get a yes no answer
okay and again the critical point here
is that
addition and multiplication took
encodings and output
and output encodings took encoding open
encoding right so everything was still
hidden
in terms of what was going on this is
the only operation that actually yields
the result in the clear
right and this is what we're going to be
exploiting okay
does that make sense any questions yes
you have uh subset one when you're doing
multiplication we can't can't multiply
something with a subset one
by another thing in subset one that's
right yes the levels are really like
horizontal now it's like one through k
yeah yeah that's the right way to think
about it think about the hypercube and
you know you've got the level
yeah exactly okay all right
so um okay
eventually we'll get to some
computational hardness assumptions a
concrete one over this framework but
but not right now and
this framework i'm thinking about just
as an ideal multi-linear
sort of setting uh everything i'm
talking about would you know make sense
especially in light of the most recent
clt 15
work one point that i want to stress
that sun jim also mentioned
is that in the obfuscation setting
we need only a restricted subset
of the sort of general multilinear maps
something that we called multilinear
jigsaw puzzles in our paper
okay and here again i'm talking about
constructing obfuscation
so this is just in case you are worried
about those attacks which you know we
all should be
thinking about them um the key points
here
are that in the setting
no low level encodings of xero are given
out okay so you don't have to worry
about that at all
there's no need for randomization or
anything like that
and furthermore in fact you don't even
need to sample an element even you don't
even need that algorithm that sanji
mentioned
only the master key holder the one who
generated all the z's and everything
that sanji was talking about
he's the only person that ever needs to
encode any given element
okay and he has all the cards right he
knows he knows all the secrets
so um so this is straightforward
um and as i mentioned this is this this
is actually critical to avoid
um uh attacks with previous
uh uh uh multilinear candidates with
clt15
we don't need to even need to worry
about this even without this it seems to
be everything seems to be okay
for the next like few weeks for the next
few weeks yes you know
all right so now
let's go into the actual construction so
i want to obfuscate
a matrix branching program now matrix
branching programs
are great when i go home and i feel like
coding up some little app for myself
i usually write the app in a matrix
branching program because it is so
intuitive and and and so you know so
easy to use as a language
um they're great you know i you know
interfaces for that for
this thing all right so so what is
a matrix branching program um a matrix
branching program
consists of 2k and it's not a
coincidence that k
is related to the k we just saw moments
ago
2k matrices think of k as being a large
number
okay um and uh
on the other hand we also have an n bit
input
in this example let's think of n just
being three so n equals three
and i'm going to color code the input so
the first bit
of the input is blue the second bit of
the input is red
the third bit of the input is green and
so on and so forth
okay now if i want to
evaluate such a matrix branching program
on a particular input
what i'll do is multiply the matrices
that are selected by those input bits
right
so if the first bit is one then i'll
pick this matrix the second bit is 0
then i'll take this matrix and so on and
so forth
okay and a matrix branching program has
a promise
the way that i'm describing it here is
the barrington style of our matrix
matching program
it has a promise that whenever you
evaluate it honestly in this way
then the result is always one of two
different matrices it's always either
the identity matrix
in that case we think of the function as
evaluating to zero
or it is some other fixed matrix b which
is not the identity matrix
if the output is one okay
so that is what a matrix branching
program is
um yeah here's just an example right so
if we if we had some specific input
let's say one zero zero
then i would pick these inputs pick
these matrices multiply them all
together and i would get either i
or b depending on what the output is
parameter
because of barrington's theorem it's not
going to be important uh
yeah even 2x2 is enough but yeah but but
um but a constant by constant square
invertible matrices we're talking about
here okay
so um i have a confession to make
i don't actually program in this
programming language i know
it's a sad thing for you guys to hear um
but
let me just give you uh some sense
though
right of how you would use a matrix
branching program
so suppose i want to make a matrix
branching program just for the xor
function
okay so i have just a two bit input x1
and x2 and i want to xor them
so the way to think about it is that
i'll associate
zero with the identity matrix
and one with the anti-identity matrix
right and if you think about this
it just works right in this case again b
which is the
the output for one is this anti-identity
matrix
and you know if you just make these
matrices
accordingly identity times the identity
of identity anti-identity times n
tangent equals identity
so that respects xor on the other hand
if you have an identity then you're
going to keep the other matrix which you
can respect sexor
right so this is just one little little
tiny example
of how you can program in matrix
branching program language
in fact there's a beautiful theorem of
barrington
that shows that all log depth
circuits so any nc1 circuit has a
polynomial size
excuse me matrix branching program okay
so
despite the fact that we're only going
to be obfuscating these
uh somewhat strange looking programs
we can actually if we're successful here
we can obfuscate all log depth circuits
which will be enough for us
as craig will tell us tomorrow we can
bootstrap once we get to nc1 to all of p
slash volley
to all polynomial size circuits all
right
so um let's start to make some progress
what are we going to do to build an
obfuscation
so the first step is
the killian randomization this is from
killian's
classic paper from 1989
where we do the following we're going to
pick
k minus 1 completely random
matrices actually random invertible
matrices over zn
okay just
think of r 0 and r k as being the
identity matrix okay so i'm just going
to
define them as as such and then what we
do is we just take each of these
matrices
that came from the original matrix
branching program the one that we wanted
to obfuscate
and we just randomize it by left
multiplying by r i minus 1
and right multiplying by ri inverse
okay so you can see
immediately that because of the
structure right we have the inverse
in front and then non-inverted one
behind
this does not affect the matrix product
right the matrix product exactly
is preserved here right so
um so that's good
as i mentioned so r0 and rk i'm defining
to be identity matrix they're not random
okay so excuse me
uh so this is the first step we're going
to apply this killing randomization
okay and we get all these tilded
versions of our matrices
okay and now why do we do this
again one nice reason is because it
preserves the matrix product so it's a
nice randomization right it has this
magical
property of like everything canceling
out right at the last second
right the very last moment the last r
cancels out and out pops the
the uh the output so that's nice
but it has another really beautiful
property uh which again kilian showed
that if you restrict to a single input
x right so again think about only the
matrices corresponding to a single input
x here
right then you can statistically
simulate
the entire joint distribution of all of
these matrices
knowing only the final product
okay so given only the final product we
can actually simulate
every single one of these matrices okay
it's just statistically close
okay um this is actually very easy to
prove
let me just prove it to you by example
okay so think of the cases of two two
matrices
okay suppose i have just m1 times r and
then r inverse times
m2 the general case follows an inductive
way okay
so why can we simulate these just rename
okay remember m0 i mean m1 and m2
these matrices are invertible i
mentioned that at the very beginning
a matrix matching program only has
invertible matrices
so if i just call r prime m2 inverse r
then
if r was a random matrix a random
invertible matrix then
r prime is a random invertible matrix
right i've just renamed it nothing else
okay and once i have this renaming
then what is m1r it's just m1 m2
r prime and what is r inverse m2 is just
r prime inverse
right so in order to
construct these two matrices i only need
to know the product
m1 m2 right and the same idea just
works in a straightforward induction to
get the
to get killings result statistically
closest
right this is a it's perfect the way i
described it
if the matrices are chosen for example
uniformly at random then there's a
slight chance they're not invertible so
they're just little things like that
but absolutely you should think about it
as perfect
okay
um good so
all right so now we have these uh
matrices uh
killian randomized right um
we haven't used muscle linear maps yet
so let's throw that in
right let's take all of these matrices
and just element by element encode them
at sort of the most obvious levels right
i could encode the first pair of
matrices at level one level two level
three level four like this
these are all disjoint sets if i do
matrix product that is the
classic example of a multilinear
operation right
and it yields uh the final product
at the final level where we can zero
test and discover if we've got an
identity matrix or not right
so again so far just the most
straightforward thing we could do once
we have these matrices and we have
multiple linear maps and we want to use
them
right okay um
i right good
so a first question to ask is
maybe this is already an obfuscation
right we've done some work
uh we've thrown killian and and
multilingual maps of the problem maybe
this has already solved it
for us um it turns out
no there is actually exactly one
in a provable sense key obstacle
uh remaining which is something that we
call the input mixing attack
so what is that um suppose i'm an
adversary right
and i have all of these this is my
obfuscation right my obfuscation
consists of
encoded versions of these kilian
randomized matrices
right but i'm an adversary i can do
whatever i want
right let's say i'm a nice guy though
mostly nice
so i pick this matrix corresponding to
x one equals one i multiply it by this
matrix corresponding to the input zero
this major group of the input zero now
if i was being honest i have to pick
this matrix right
because i have to continue to be
faithful to the input that i've
committed to so far
but i'm not an honest guy when it comes
to this part of the attack
suppose that i do this instead i just
multiply by
the wrong matrix right nothing has
prevented this so far
right this is a completely valid thing
to do all the multi-linear maps allow it
killian's randomization allows it right
the r's are fixed
for each pair of matrices so they'll
still cancel out
right and in fact this is a real attack
and there are um examples
where these kinds of input mixing
attacks actually do leak critical
information about a secret
um and in general we do not know how to
bound
the information that's leaked by these
kinds of input mixing attacks
actually there's some really interesting
questions there really interesting open
questions there about
bounding information in in in this sort
of a setting but
that's not what i'm here to talk about
this is an attack this is a problem
right we have to prevent this from
happening
okay so here's what i'm going to do
i'm going to try to exploit these
multilinear maps a little bit more
so first let me do something harmless ah
yeah
if you had a program where each input
was only read once
uh would that sort of this already work
or yes yes in that case there's there
would be no there are no attacks that we
uh that we would know about um but yeah
there aren't really very many
interesting
programs like that that only that are
read once um
yeah in that case
submission of the program evaluated on
all inputs i can
write but i could i can add the two
matrices at any level
right now i can multiply them together
what i get is a summation of
that's true but if all you want is i o
it's not an attack and remember i'm only
talking about io so i will not talk
about getting vb in this talk i'll
mention it if you ask me a question
later but right now i'm only talking
about i o so i'm not even going to worry
about
about preventing that attack because
it's not an attack on i o
right given the truth table of function
you can do that yourself
sure this wouldn't be a baby right and
and i'm not going to even talk about a
vp candidate today um
although again i can mention the little
things that have to be different yeah
no no craig will also not talk about
that
um i have to define some boundaries i
guess right around craig
yeah so but uh that's actually a good
point so what you know they're saying is
that
for any functions even functions that we
are hoping to get dvd security this will
not give you bbb security because of
the right no hold on but but as you very
well know as my co-author
this what i've said right now will not
work but
we do know how to fix it right and
this construction will not give vb but
it will give io as far as we know
okay and that's all i was claiming so
far
okay so what am i going to do first i'm
going to do something just harmless
i'm going to just add a few more levels
just
make a copy of one and call it one prime
so now my set
i'm going to abuse notation a little bit
now it's going to consist of 1 through k
and 1 prime through k prime okay so far
i haven't done anything this is just
the same scheme there's no i'm just
renaming the zs
in in sanjim's language um
but once i've done this i can i can use
it to get something
so what's the what's the idea
the idea is i'm just going to take these
primed indices here
and just rotate them okay
now why is the good idea because
think about it this way right in order
to get to the top level
i have to pick up every single index
right
one way i can do that is by picking this
one this one and this one
right and that would
allow me to get one four and seven and
one prime four prime and seven prime
right i'm sorry i think i didn't mention
it uh just a second let me just go back
uh oh
sorry i have too many animations
all right okay yeah right there what did
i do
i wanted to focus in on the matrices
that corresponded to a single input
right so i got rid of all the other
matrices because that's where the
problem was right input mixing
if i have the matrices that correspond
to the blue input
once you start at zero i want you to
continue with zero if you start with one
then i want you to continue with one
right that's the that's our objective
okay
so we do this rotation and
it will end up accomplishing our
objective right because if i need to get
to the to the final set i can union all
these
or i could union all these but there's
no other way
that i can union these sets to get to
the final set
right we can kind of think of them
visually as these like jigsaw puzzle
pieces
right that suppose i have these pieces
well i can put them together to make my
nice little rectangle
on the other hand what if i have these
pieces that are oriented oppositely
right these three also i can put
together
but as soon as i pick this piece if i
want to make a rectangle i have no
choice i have to pick this one and this
one
as soon as i pick this piece i have no
choice i have to pick this one and this
one i can't combine
these two sides of these jigsaw puzzle
pieces right
so this is this notion of a straddling
set
that we introduced um in the work with
uh uh bose at all um
and it exactly solves this problem for
us right it exactly solves the problem
of input mixing attacks
because again now just by the rules of
multi-linear maps
the adversary is just not allowed to mix
these inputs together anymore
okay um so uh
so we're almost to a place where we can
take a take a nice
uh uh pause so what's our obfuscation
construction finally
right we have taken our matrices
we've killed and randomized them we've
encoded them at the levels that are
represented by these
pieces right and that's it okay this
actually gives a plausible obfuscation
construction
there are no known attacks on this uh on
this construction
and in fact if we add just a tiny bit
more randomness
okay i'm just going to take each of
these matrices
and also add a completely independent
random scalar
alpha ib that's different for each
matrix
which again doesn't change whether the
final thing is going to be zero or one
right so this does not affect
correctness in any way it doesn't harm
correctness in any way
then in fact we can even prove that
there are no
algebraic attacks on this scheme okay
so um let's uh take a break now and then
when i
when we come back we can talk about how
to actually prove
uh prove this kind of security